[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese fantasy teen
film called underachiever spoilers ahead
watch out and take
care in the opening scene some military
men spy on a car zooming through the
desert they are after something that the
driver possesses they chase after the
man on their motorcycles and eventually
stop him but the case they were
desperately looking for is empty a
flashback shows us that the man had
found a rare black crystal in the desert
he knew bad people were after it so he
put it inside his water bottle and
buried it somewhere in the sand the
leader of the group is furious but even
the man cannot tell for sure where he
buried the valuables following that we
are introduced to the protagonist of the
film zhang tianci he is a 22 year old
high schooler who has repeated the same
class thrice after failing three times
for the past consecutive years tianzi is
known as the most familiar face of the
school as no student has been in the
school as long as he has his best friend
shang fey is also the same but has one
up on tianzi since he has only failed
twice the duo is the certified loser
among its classmates in one of the
classes tianzi dozes off and falls off
of his chair everyone laughs as the
teacher calls him an invertebrate before
punishing him he is frequently looked
down upon and bullied by his classmates
but he still has hope that one day he
will pass the university exam the source
of his motivation is one of his sweet
classmates named xiaoyeon she gives him
candy every day encouraging him to do
better she is also one of the few who
doesn't laugh at the jokes made about
him because of her nature many guys are
in love with her including tiance's
biggest bully lou he is good at studies
and sports which makes him think that he
is better than everyone else especially
tian c he makes advances at xiaoyeon
every chance he gets but she is not in
the least interested in him moreover she
seems to only hand the candy to tianci
and shanghai which makes him furious he
takes out his frustration by bullying
tiancey calling him an orphan and urging
him to close the books even though he is
studying shang fei comes to his friend's
aid pulling him away before things
escalate at night tianzi returns to an
empty home and we find out that he has
no family he lives on government welfare
programs which makes his life even more
difficult he studies until midnight
determined to pass the exam this time
but the thought of failure doesn't leave
his head after that he goes to a nearby
desert to collect garbage and sell it
for some extra money to his luck he
finds the hidden water bottle with the
crystals inside of it on his way back
home he bumps into lou and xiaoyeon lou
makes fun of him as always and shakes
the garbage bag when the bottle falls
out xiaoyeon picks it up to return it to
tian c at this moment a surveillance
camera catches her face with the water
bottle somewhere else the military group
that had been looking for the bottle
sees the footage and targets lou and
xiaoyon who are the only ones visible
back at home tianzi opens the bottle and
finds the rare black crystals inside he
doesn't think much of it though and goes
to sleep after putting the bottle down
by his bed unbeknownst to him the
crystal is working its magic and giving
him special powers that he is not ready
for the next morning a group of thugs is
bothering xiaoyeon on their way to
school tiance and shang faye see this
shang fae wants to run away but tianzi
cannot leave her alone with the thugs he
stops the gang from harassing her but is
in turn beaten up by them they tear his
notebooks and forcefully make him eat
one of the pages by the time they're
finished tiance's face is covered in
cuts and bruises at school the teacher
is informed about the fight but instead
of taking action against the thugs he
puts the blame on tian c for causing
trouble xiaoyeon and shang fei take
tianzi's side but the teacher just
dismisses the matter and asks them to
forget about it as well more problems
add up when tianci walks into the class
and is hit by a duster to his face lou
is mad at him for skipping his
whiteboard rubbing duties to his
annoyance xiaoyun takes a stand for
tianci and cleans the board on his
behalf during a lecture tianzi
accidentally drops his phone to the
floor disturbing everyone fed up with
his behavior the teacher asks him to
come to the front and solve an algebra
problem to tiance's surprise he seems to
understand the problem he efficiently
solves it in front of the class and
surprises everyone including himself liu
tries to undermine his intelligence by
saying that the method he used is wrong
but the teacher claims that it's just a
bit complex suddenly tianci remembers
that the paper he was made to eat in the
morning consisted of similar
mathematical problems he puts two and
two together and figures out he might
have gained a superpower of memorization
when he eats a paper with some form of
information on it after school he tells
shanghai everything about the revelation
but shang fade doesn't believe him
instead he thinks that tianzi must have
studied the problem and forgotten about
it still to test if he is telling the
truth he makes tianci eat a paper with
all the fighting techniques that he has
been learning in the karate class on his
way back home tianzi again encounters
the thugs from the morning the leader is
the comb man who fixes his hair before
and after every fight he challenges
tiance to stand against them unaware
that tianci knows everything about
fighting like bruce lee the fight ends
in only a minute as tianzi defeats all
of them with his outstanding techniques
the comb man vows to never mess with him
again the next day in class lu throws a
duster at him again but this time tianci
catches it without even looking shang
fei finally believes that he might have
superpowers this gives him an
outstanding idea their school's
basketball team is going against their
nemesis schools team hence he makes
tionci eat pages from a book about
basketball tips and tricks in the
evening the match is about to start but
since lou is the team's captain he
refuses to take tiancey in shanghai begs
him insisting that he is a great player
but lou would rather give up his
position than let tiance play with them
moreover tianzi's shoes are old and no
one has choose his size that he can
borrow the match starts and their team
begins losing immediately against the
hulks of the opponent's school they are
proven to be weak by the end of the
first half they haven't scored a single
basket and are losing by 26 points
during halftime xiaoyen brings tiancia a
pair of shoes from her brother who has
the same shoe size as he does lou is mad
that no one on the team played well he
insults his teammates which in turn
causes an internal fight as punishment
for lou the teacher replaces him with
tian c
initially lou doesn't mind because
they're losing the game anyway but then
tianzi starts scoring one basket after
another surprising everyone as time
passes he catches up to the opponent's
score and gives them a tough time lou
makes his best friend play badly so the
team won't win the match and tiance
won't get the credit he hopes for but
tianzi manages to score a difficult
basket and impresses everyone even more
after the match he is the talk of the
school meanwhile lou who is used to
being the best at everything is furious
that someone like tian c is coming for
his throne his friend reveals that he
heard tiance and shang fei talking about
something strange that involved papers
the duo realizes something is wrong and
decides to look into the matter the
following day tiance returns the shoes
to xiaoyeon thanking her for always
being there for him she had always
believed in him even when he was
considered a loser now that he is one of
the popular ones tiance thinks he owes
his success to her they walk home
together and begin dating starting that
day in the following scene we see them
hanging out by the sea singing together
and falling in love with each other lou
is furious and mixes laxative into a
drink and hands it to a girl to deliver
it to tianci he wants to humiliate him
in front of xiaoyon but the plan fails
when the girl hands the drink to the
teacher instead the teacher does some
questionable things during the lecture
that day but the students just laugh it
off as the days pass tianci eats more
papers instead of studying but he soon
discovers that the paper memory is
taking up space in his head and he is
beginning to forget events that happen
in real life if he continues using the
power of the magical crystal he might
one day forget who he is however he is
scared that if he returns back to being
a loser xiaoyeon might not want to be
with him anymore that afternoon the
leader of the men who are looking for
the crystal finds the comb men he
threatens the group to tell him where
lou and xiaoyeon are after school lou
insists on walking xiaoyon home even
though she refuses repeatedly suddenly
someone attacks them from behind and
takes them to the gang's hideout they
are asked about the crystal which they
of course know nothing about but as the
men explained to them what the crystal
is lou realizes that tianzi must have it
he tells them about him and gives them
his phone number somewhere else tianzi
tells shang fei about the memory
problems he's been facing recently he
reveals that he doesn't want to use the
crystal's power anymore shang fei is
disheartened because he has grown to
like the new tianci but he understands
the decision just then they get a call
from the kidnappers who threaten tiancey
to come to the hideout with the crystal
if he wants his friends back alive
tianzi knows that even after he hands
them what they want it is likely they
will not spare the group hence he eats a
bunch of papers with different fighting
skills to teach the gang a lesson before
leaving he also hands shang fei a purple
gift box to give to xiaoyen if he
doesn't return from the mission in the
following scene he walks into the
hideout at gunpoint and hands them the
bottle but the leader is furious to find
it empty he fires at lou and xiaoyon to
retaliate as tianci begs him to let them
go lou panics and starts running causing
a shootout he gets shot in the leg and
hides behind a bunch of boxes with
xiaoyon the antagonist manages to get to
xiaoyeon and holds her hostage against
tianci tianci in turn attacks him with a
knife but after a bit of struggle he is
stabbed in the abdomen the leader has
complete control over the situation when
the screen dips to black a few days
later lou is in the classroom bragging
to his classmates about how he saved the
day like a hero even though he was shot
somewhere else shang fei gives xiaoyeon
the gift box that he was given by tianzi
it consists of the towel she used to
help tiance during the basketball match
the candy wrapper and many little things
that he saved from their time together
just when we think he didn't make it out
alive tiance appears in front of the two
a flashback shows us that even when he
was severely injured he took out the
knife from his abdomen and killed the
leader in the final scene tiancey and
xiaoyeon hug before the trio walks away
while engaging in a cheerful
conversation subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching